change the world
[Music]
20 years ago I'm in this meeting I'm in
this huge there's this huge conference
table that seats 20 people I'm the only
one there I'm in the 29th floor in the
financial district there's this window I
can see the entire Bay and Alcatraz and
everything
and again I'm about your age at this
time it's a conference room of my
largest investor this guy I'll call him
Joe and Joe is this bigger than life
person hedge fund magnet household name
I'm sitting there and I am petrified I
am shaking
and my my throat is dry and I can hear
Joe walking toward me and
then I hear the the knob turn and he
walks in as he always did just huge
personality Graham you know he's all
excited and I'm sitting there and he
sits down and he can see something's
like really wrong I tell Joe
that his investment in my firm is down
50 he's lost half his money and
it wasn't his firm's money it was his
personal money
I can just see the energy drain out of
them and
the worst part is he's trying so hard to
be positive because he knows if he says
the wrong thing like he's just gonna
crush me because I I was I was so
fragile and he was my you know he's my
largest investor
I have been told no by over a hundred
people raising my first fund and there
were about five or six people like Joe
who said yes because not because I had
any track record because I didn't
because he believed in me you know just
me he was investing in Graham Weaver
and uh that's what I had to show for him
I lost half his money and it was the
worst day of my
career at that point and even to this
day the thing that I thought I knew
about investing back then it was all
wrong what I thought I knew at the time
was rule one don't lose money
and Rule two never forget rule one so I
spent all that time I spent all that
time just playing for like playing small
like just trying to protect my downside
trying not to lose really hard so we
bought businesses like at a discount to
their net asset value
and even when things went right it
didn't go that right but there were
three times I wrote literally an
investment memo that it is
mathematically impossible to lose money
on this investment and we lost money all
three times
so I what I what I learned is that
it's kind of like imagine your imagine
you're you start dating and your only
purpose of dating is not get your heart
broken and you're going to have one foot
in and one foot out
and even if you have a even if you have
a good date it's not going to be that
great because you're not really in it
but the more likely outcome is you're
going to guarantee the very outcome
you're trying to avoid which is you're
going to get your heart broken
and so I started deciding over the over
the next 30 Years
I started realizing that that was 180
degrees from what I should be doing and
investing
that no matter what you do in this life
like if you're going to invest there's
going to be downside you you're you're
never going to get that to zero
you can reduce it maybe a little bit but
the more valuable part and the magic is
what can you do on the upside
you know what what can get when it goes
right you know and clazza right assume
success what happens if things go well
in 30 years of being a professional
investor I can summarize great investing
in a single word
which is asymmetry and you are looking
for the biggest possible outcome
relative to your risk and your risk
typically is just losing one times your
money that's all you're going to lose so
you want to be stacking criteria on top
of each other where it becomes
asymmetric
so for example if you have the criteria
of an amazing management team that is
going to work super hard and hire well
and they're going to be in this industry
that's got infinite capacity they can
redeploy Capital at high rates of return
and and and you can hold it for 10 years
and they want to keep going and you
stack those on top of each other they
don't stack linearly they stock they
stack log rhythmically
and and you can have an almost infinite
outcome you're not playing for one and a
half or two times your money as we were
in the early days you can be playing for
10 20 50 100 tons of money with that
with that criteria and you don't have to
do many of those investments in your
lifetime so as I started realizing that
this was how I was living my life invest
investing it also was how I was living
my personal life
and I was just playing small I was
planning not to lose
I was
just trying to just trying not to lose
and so what I'm going to share with you
today
is how to live an asymmetric life
and there are four principles
and if you get one of these principles
right you will you would dramatically
dramatically improve your life
if you get two or three right you'll
have this magical incredible life but if
you can run the table on all four you
can have literally an infinite life you
can have almost anything that you want
and you can live with joy and you can
sustain and you can have energy and you
can sustain that for decades and I can
tell you this from experience
principle one is do hard things
so we have this view we have this
thought that life is supposed to be easy
and that there's and that and that
Comfort is where we're going to gain
uh happiness so you can order Harmony
Bowl from sweet Greens on your on your
app you can you can you can binge watch
succession and Ted lasso and you can
have you can have you can have a life of
ease and and that will give you a quick
hit of dopamine but make no mistake that
is not the path it is exactly the
opposite I rode crew in college and the
way you measure progress in rowing and
the way you kind of determine what boat
you're gonna as Logan was saying is you
you have an ERG test you sit on a rowing
machine you wrote two thousand meters as
hard as you can
and the saying is if you get done with
that herb test and you can pull one more
stroke you didn't pull hard enough
so it's going to hurt no matter what you
do it's going to hurt
well throughout the course of the Season
like the day that I show up which would
be like September 1st from that date all
the way through March I would improve my
work time by 20 seconds roughly from the
first date with all conditioning
everything we do but so a big part of
that would be rowing stadium stairs uh
late lifting weights and on and on it
was grueling and it was it was a lot
but all that stuff I just said would
take about six months and only 10
seconds of that 20 would come from that
the other 10 seconds would come in the
first two weeks
you're like what so what happened in the
first two weeks to give you 10 seconds
I'll tell you what didn't happen you
didn't change your cardiovascular
fitness you didn't change your strength
you didn't change your VO2 max or your
Technique
all you changed is your comfort to be
uncomfortable you realize that you could
push yourself a lot harder than you
thought you could
that's all that changed that was half of
the gains I would get all year would
just be me reminding myself that I had a
lot more than I thought I did
and then at 750 meters
with when my heart rate's 175 beats a
minute I'm not gonna you know I can keep
going
this chart right here shows our lives
and this is what happens we get kind of
complacent you know or we or we get we
get comfortable and if we want to move
forward and get to the next Peak
the magic of is to understand that your
life is almost always going to get worse
first
any change that you want to make
is almost always going to get worse
first so you're in a relationship and
you have to have a hard conversation
that particular night your life is going
to get a little worse and then you're
going to come out the other and it's
going to get better or if you need to
leave a relationship that's you
shouldn't be in the first place your
life's going to get worse first
if you want to change careers and you
want to learn something new you're going
to go down the learning curve your
salary is probably going to go down
you're going to not be good at your job
when you first start your life's going
to get worse first and you want to start
a new habit you want to take a cold
shower you want to meditate you want to
start exercising it's going to get worse
first
and you're gonna and you're going to
follow this pattern but you need to
realize that the thing that's keeping
you there is the first move is always
going to be
worse
and eventually you're gonna eventually
what's gonna happen is these these
downward curves are going to get a lot
shallower because you know what the
biggest part of that curve is it's just
fear
the biggest part of that curve is just
so the more you put yourself in
situations where you do hard things the
shallower and shallower those divots are
going to get because because you're
going to remove that fear just like I
mentioned in the rowing example
I had no fear at 2000 meters then or at
1500 meters everything that you want in
this life is on the other side of worse
first
if you want to have an asymmetric life
do hard things
second principle if you want to have an
asymmetric life
do your thing
do your thing when I graduated from
school
probably like many of you I had a choice
to make there were two basically two
options
there was
there was a firm that came to recruit on
campus and I knew I could do it as what
I did before Business School
big private Equity Firm there was a
number of my classmates went with me
there was a salary and a bonus and free
lunches and it was it was really clear
and
and then there was there was another
path which is I'd done these as late
Logan said I started doing this crazy
stuff in business school with buying
companies on my credit cards and like
but I was like I don't even know how
that's going to work like I don't I
don't know what that looks like I don't
know how to get started I don't know how
to raise money whatever so so I chose I
chose uh the path of of going to the big
firm
let me tell you what happened during
that time
my boss is like here's what you need to
be vice president you know here's your
goal post so I'm going to like Sprint
like hell to those gold posts as fast as
I can as all of you are right you're
competitive and you want to go there
so I got on early flights and you know
would start bidding on businesses and
they'd tell me which companies to go to
and I would do those and I would I would
throw I threw myself in with everything
that I had
and if I had kids at the time I would
have been home late and I would have you
know missed Little League games and
the thing is
Buddha figured out something 2 800 years
ago the first principle of Buddhism
which is called duka
which is that there's going to be
suffering
either way
there's no easy path
there's no safe path
there's no path of ease there's no path
that's that's going to be
that's going to make everything right
you're going to suffer either way
I'm sorry to be the one to tell you that
but I'm 20 years out of school and it's
it's the truth truest thing I'm probably
going to say today
life is suffering and so choose
something worth suffering for
foreign
the other thing you're missing in this
equation of your exp is you're going to
do an expected value calculation right
but there's one thing you're not
factoring into that equation which is
you're not factoring in U when you're
turned on
I went to this dinner in New York and it
was a bunch of other private it was
ridiculous this dinner there's a whole
bunch of private Equity people there and
uh we go to this restaurant in New York
it's one of those restaurants that has
like the ice and the fish's heads are
like in the ice and you can like go up
and you point to the fish that you want
and for the privilege of doing that you
pay like four times more for the same
fish but you but they're in the ice and
then like we had a reservation at like
eight o'clock at night and then even
with a reservation we still didn't get
seated till like 9 15 which is like my
bedtime typically and and then we're at
the dinner and this one woman comes in
from with a with a um a driver and
everything and she's from The Hamptons
she's if I had a counter she said the
words Hampton's probably 13 times at
dinner I was like just out of curiosity
do you happen to have a place in the
Hamptons because I'm kind of confused
and uh but but there's this one guy
there Dave okay
and Dave is in the same business he's in
the same role as me we're in the same
he's at a competing firm and Dave starts
going off Dave is like I just won this
deal you won't believe this here's what
happened there was this dead this is
what we did on the dead covenants we
didn't step them down we had the debt to
ebitda that didn't step down for two
quarters we're going to save 50 basis
points on our interest and we use pro
forma adjusted trailing 12 months
yesterday ebitda times 365 and we
therefore we're getting an extra quarter
of a turn of debt and that's going to
help our and he's going on and on and on
and I'm thinking Dave thinks he's
colonizing Mars you know he's so excited
about this like he's in his head you
know he's colonizing Mars and I'm
thinking to myself two things I'm
thinking first
Dave is going to kick my ass because I
don't care at all about any of this
stuff
and and the other thing I realized is
that this is what Dave had written his
business school essay about
he was living it he was doing the thing
that he wanted to be doing
and what what you're you're not you're
not going to win doing someone else's
dream you can survive for a little while
but you're not going to win
if you want to live an asymmetric life
do hard things
and do your thing
the uh the third principle
is do it for decades
and and this is a this is one that
probably a lot of people don't want to
hear so like I have conversations with a
lot of you and the conversation will go
something like this
my roommates
sisters friend Megan is trading Dogecoin
and made two million dollars and that
could have been me you know because I
just wasn't in the right place at the
right time and her friend Kristen is day
trading board ape nfts and like makes
thirty thousand dollars of passive
income and all this stuff right
and and that's that could have been you
if you were just in the right place but
you're all behind you know you're not
there yet you're just you're like way
behind where you should be and I thought
that same thing when I was here when I
was here it was internet 1.0 b2c like
petfood.com
my classmates all went into that and if
Dave at that dinner had asked me
although he Dave was not a good
conversationalist so he never asked me
but had
had Dave asked me about what I was
excited about I would have talked about
building this business this little label
business I would have talked about the
culture we were trying to build at this
company I would have talked about how we
punch way above our weight and we hired
this person for their his attributes and
no one thought of this and we pulled him
from this public company and then we
were putting Lean Manufacturing in the
plant we were building a culture where
people wanted to stay and spend their
lives and we were training people from
high school to be press operators and
Dave would have been like
Graham thinks he's freaking changing the
world you know with this little label
business
um but what
so what we didn't factor in at the time
was I was willing to just keep going
because I loved it
if you think of the equation for returns
it's 1 plus r to the n
is quadratic the N is the number of
years you you compound that's the most
powerful part of the equation is n
and and so if you think of me my rate of
growth it almost doesn't matter I'm
growing every year year three I'm a
better CEO than I was in year two in
year five I'm better than I was in year
four but you're 23 I mean you're 23.
and if you if you take that R which is
how great how fast you're improving and
you can work on that r a little bit with
Executive coaching and writing out your
goals and meditating and trying to work
and be good at your job and now you put
a 23 on it
you can be the best in the world
just about the it's just about how long
you're willing to do it
that's the most powerful Factor
and there is no obstacle that will not
yield to you
excited about something
for a decade or longer if you want to
have an asymmetric life do hard things
do your thing and do it for decades
the fourth and final point
is the most important of all
in 2008 we had just started we finally
got going at Alpine
and things are start you know we're
starting to get going and
bam we just got flattened by the
recession I mean flattened we were not
well positioned it turned out we
wouldn't raise a fund for five years
train my savings account to make payroll
we had seven companies in default
including our largest business
was in default at the time uh
so for some reason during that time I
had I had lunch with this this guy
named JP Flom and he was an executive
coach I was like what the hell's an
executive coach that sounds I had no
idea what that even was
but he was super he was super persuasive
and he's like hey let me level with you
it ain't going so great in the Executive
coaching business right now either so
I'm gonna give you this you know
incredible thing that I just pitched you
for half price which was still a ton of
money for me which I just drained my
savings account and I just was and and I
don't know why to this day that I said
yes I don't know why
but I did I said yes
so I hired my first ever executive coach
I would not know it until much later
that I actually hired probably one of
the best coaches in the world we start
talking about the largest business that
we have and and how it's not going well
and he's like well what you know what's
going on you know what are you doing
how's this going and
I said you know JP have you not seen the
news in like the last you know year the
Market's down 50 percent Lehman Brothers
blew up Maryland just got bought Banks
aren't lending like that you know like
we're we're toast you know
he's like
it's like well it sounds like you're
you're just kind of helpless then Graham
and then he's like oh you sorry it's
like you know oh you know so I was like
all right well what do we do he's like
all right here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna write a story okay and
there's three rules to writing this
story
the first one is it's going to take
place five years from now we're gonna
get out of the fog award you're right
you can't you can't look past where you
are six inches in front of your face
let's go out five years the second rule
is let's start with Nirvana I don't want
to hear something that's mediocre I want
to hear what would happen what would you
do if you would knew you would not fail
would be your genie goal as Logan said
and third he said
the how is the killer of all great
dreams
forget the how I don't care about the
how right now
I just want to hear about the dream
turns out with those three rules it's
pretty fun exercise
I get to say I get to go out five years
I don't have to worry about how I'm
gonna do it and I get to pick anything I
want like that who doesn't want to do
that so we put in place this this plan
for this this one company we just
started with one company and what we
basically said is all right we're going
to hire this best CEO you could imagine
in the world
the CEO is going to build this
incredible team our technology is going
to be better than anyone else and
therefore we're going to have better up
time we're gonna hire the sales team
we're going to start winning contracts
we've never you know we've been losing
all of them we're going to you know and
then we're going to start buying
competitors because they're down too and
we can do add-on you know and and we had
this incredible thing and I was like and
that was really fun
and then I started saying well that was
great you know but that there's no way
we're going to do that like it was just
so aspirational aspirational by the way
is a euphemism for
how the hell are we going to go the way
that's gonna happen it was it was
aspirational
she's like well what's the first step
first step is hire a CEO it turns out in
2008 a recession that's a pretty good
time to hire a CEO we spent six months
and we brought on the best CEOs names
Mark stroke he's been and he he's a
great friend of mine now he's a partner
at Alpine now and so we brought him on
we started doing exactly what we talked
about we started building the team we
started building the technology we've
had better up time and then when Mark
and his team got going after 18 months
we won every single contract that came
up in that business
for the next two years except one
and we just started stomping on our
competitors by the way what did are the
industry didn't change the market didn't
change our competitors didn't change we
changed we just changed our story that's
all we did we changed our story
you know don't
write a story about what happens write
your story and then make it happen
and there's so much magic in this
you you put out the thing in the
universe that you want to happen and the
universe responds
and it does and that sounds like woo-woo
you're like oh God here we go Universe
responds but what what's really
happening what's really happening is
you're putting on blinders to where you
want to go you're making goals you're
aligning your day to where you want to
go you're attracting people that want to
go to the same place that you want to go
so it's it is the universe but it's
actually there's some mechanics behind
it too that make it happen
after that experience
this I was like onto something I was
like this is Magic pure magic we started
writing stories Alpine about everything
we wrote stories about how we could have
mbas become CEOs right when they
graduate we wrote stories about building
cultures where people would want to
spend their whole careers where people
could feel like they mattered and feel
like their their life you know had
meaning and that they were contributing
we wrote stories about companies we
wrote stories about sourcing
and just pretty much every single thing
we ever wrote came true
from that point on
I had the privilege of meeting with Joe
very recently
from the very first story I told you
and
this Joe Joe this is 20 20 years 20
years after the first story
and Joe stayed I didn't tell you what
Joe was incredibly gracious
I could tell how hard it was for him to
do that but he was gracious because he
too had had some struggles in here in
his early days and he understood that
things take time and that they're hard
so he stayed with us and he was a
supporter of us for the last 20 years
so Joe left the hedge fund and and he
devoted his life to climate change
so we sit down and we had an hour
meeting we spend the first 55 minutes
hearing all about climate change and all
the stuff he's working on he's just
bouncing off the walls he's so excited
he was doing his thing
and then as we do every single time that
we meet you know I give him our our DAC
and our performance sheet
and Joe's been a big investor of ours
and you know his foundation that does
climate change is is our investor
and he looks at this sheet
and he uh
and he just he just looked at me and he
just said you know go Grandma you did it
she did it you know 20 23 years later
like this is amazing he said thank you
and
you know just like back then
when I had to
have that meeting over and over
I had the privilege of having this
meeting over and over
and I meet with college endowments and
boards that are like that that will say
literally like you've helped us fund 10
years of financial aid for our school
or another another University like shows
us that this is going to go a huge part
of the budget toward the buildings that
they're building
you know we have investors that are
running cancer foundations and are doing
climate change work and
it's it's been it's been a long ride but
a really glorious one
and uh
I go back to that meeting with Dave who
said you know Graham's buying these
stupid label printing companies and
thinks he's changing the world
and I may be having a little hopefully a
little bit of an impact
so where does this leave all of you
all of you right now are about to
graduate
and a lot of you have picked have chosen
jobs and careers
and each of you has an opportunity no
matter where you are in your life
whether you're you know a parent who's
even watching here tonight
like you have an opportunity to write
the story you want to have you can write
any story that you want
you just have to start writing it
and
if you want to have an asymmetric life
do hard things do your thing do it for
decades
and rate your story
I thought I'd end with
Catalyst that I had in my life probably
the biggest Turning Point
so I rode crew in college
and as I mentioned before and I I had a
nickname in rowing which was Dreamweaver
and my last name is Weaver and so my
friends call me Dreamweaver and like
what a great name right because I mean
like who doesn't want to be Dreamweaver
so the person who gave me this name was
a guy named Monty razor and my sophomore
year he was a senior and like you know I
was not I didn't make this make the boat
as as Logan said and I wasn't very good
and he was he was in the first he was
amazing so but anyway I could still
picture like I would walk into the
rowing room and Monty would just say
dream like this and like I would just
get this surge of energy and like the
name just stuck everyone started calling
me dream it was awesome and it signified
who I was back then
well
a few years after I graduate
um I'm sitting down and my friend calls
me on the phone and says you know hey
sit you need to sit down which nothing
ever good comes of of that first intro
on a phone call and he says hey your
friend
you know Monty's gone
um he he was killed in a plane crash it
was 23.
and uh I I was just like I couldn't even
process this information I was just like
it just couldn't register I I was just
devastated but also I was kind of like
just not dealing with it
so long I go with my life year after
year and as I said I worked at this firm
and a little bit of me was you know I I
was that that Dreamweaver character that
that Monty had found in me was was
nowhere to be seen and so around that
time right at right at right as I was in
this large private active form I flew
out to New York
and I ended up having dinner with a
bunch of uh our colleagues who who had
rode crew with Monty and we ended up
talking all night and I think all of us
kind of needed a process
uh what you know what had happened and
none of us had really done that and uh
so we started talking all night and and
we're drinking and we're telling stories
about Monty and this went on pretty much
all through the night
and it was awesome we needed it you know
we needed to we needed basically to kind
of clear this out and and and and and
deal with this loss that we had
so the next day
I get on a plane to go home and uh
I just lose it you know I'm in one of
these huge planes going from San
Francisco to New York and it has two
seats and then five seats and then two
seats and I'm not right in the middle
I'm like one over but in the middle and
I'm just bawling hysterically and like
people on both sides of me are like
trying to help me and tell me if I'm
okay and the flight attendant keeps
bringing me water and I'm like I'm good
you know and like three hours I'm just I
could not contain I just like I was
exhausted too that never helps I stayed
up all night
so anyway finally I kind of get my act
together and I'm going to you know
splashing water in the bathroom it's
like three hours now into the flight
sit back down at this point
and I just remember thinking to myself
so I sit back down and like I close my
eyes and I can kind of still see that
visual where Monty says
dream when I walk into the you know the
the uh locker room
and I just remember thinking
Monty would be so disappointed in me
right now like I'm so far from the this
person that he thought I was this
Dreamweaver like I'm
I haven't seen that person in years I
was just like
and then I started thinking like
what what am I doing you know what am I
doing like I I'm playing for this
downside I'm trying to protect the
downside well guess what I just seen the
ultimate downside with my friend
and like there's really ultimately
there's no way to totally protect
against loss or downside
and so I said from this point on I'm
gonna play for the upside I'm just gonna
go big and
from that point on I did I made a
decision right then that I was never
again in my life going to say not me or
not now I was never going to say those
words again so I landed I ended my
relationship uh that night
the next day I walked in and handed in
my resignation at my firm that I'd been
working at left my crude equity and
bonus and everything
didn't have any income coming in and
then
a few days later I packed up my car
and drove out to Steamboat Springs
Colorado where my ex high school
girlfriend Cindy was living who's now
who's here and my wife of 21 years
[Music]
and in 20 in 23 years since that plane
flight I've never I've never once again
I've never said again not me not now
never
and it's been amazing it hasn't been
easy as we've talked about
so
bringing it back to you all
the biggest thing that you're going to
face
as you graduate for most of you and
through your lives
like the biggest obstacle you really
have is going to be fear if you really
boil it down
and fear is very manipulative
and it shows up in all these kinds of
different ways
and it tries to disguise itself okay it
disguises itself as being practical
I'm being practical right now it
disguises itself as I'm helping you it
disguise itself as I'm saving you
and most of all it disguises itself as
not me
not now
what I have given you today is the
antidote to fear
that's been my goal the four things that
we talked about
are ways that you can tangibly and
tactically throughout your lives
look fear in the eye and say to fear
not today today I'm going to play Big
today I'm going to play for this
asymmetric life
now is the time to do hard things
there's something that you fear right
now that's exactly where you should go
you should be doing that thing there's
something you're putting off right now
you should be doing that thing
everything that you want is on the other
side of worse first
now is the time to do your thing
there is suffering you will suffer so
pick something worth suffering for
and realize that you are underestimating
yourself at your full power when you're
excited about something that's not going
into your equation
do it for decades because you excited
for a decade knows no bounds there is no
obstacle that will not yield to you
excited for a decade
and finally write your own story
no matter where you're starting and no
matter what your role you have after
school or where where you are right now
it doesn't matter you can start today
writing your story inside of you you
have you have a you have magic you have
your own life you have something that's
special for you and there's really only
one question you need to answer which is
are you going to give yourself
permission
to lead that life to live that life and
to let that out
that's a question you're going to answer
over and over and over in your life from
now on are you going to give yourself
permission it's permission you need
so class of 2023
here we are
in class of 2023 you're about to
graduate from Stanford freaking Business
School
Stanford freaking business school you
did not come this far to play small
you came this far to move the world
now is the time now is your time thank
you so much
[Applause]
thank you